[Musique]
lorsqu'un Nick Cagny repense au jour de
la disparition de sa fille elle ne peut
pas s'empêcher de s'en vouloir
[Musique]
de pour faire le chemin pour aller au
lycée Jean Vilar tous les jours je
faisais s'il y a passé
qu'on m'a fait exprès jour là je l'ai
pas fait puis peut-être que en faisant
le coucou j'aurais pu regarder le chemin
qu'elle prenait
il y a des destins qui m'ont bouleversé
des destins et des visages
je n'oublierai jamais le sourire de
Magalie
une jeune femme qui n'aura jamais 20 ans
magalie est morte en 2001 assassiné
depuis son père vit un cauchemar
et puis il y a Karine elle aussi âgée de
19 ans elle aussi assassinée
l'histoire de ces deux jeunes filles me
fait m'interroger
comment vit-on lorsqu'on traverse la
pierre des épreuves
comment surmontons la mort d'un enfant
[Musique]
je m'appelle Eric Bertrand je suis le
papa de Magali par assassiné le 26 mars
[Musique]
qui a été assassinée à monts
Annick
Eric une mère et un père pour qui rien
ne sera plus jamais comme avant
un jour leur fille ont été retrouvées
mortes assassinées
depuis ce drame ces deux parents tentent
de continuer à vivre avec une idée en
tête
retrouvez un jour l'assassin de leur
enfant
[Musique]
Eric Bertrand a 52 ans il est chauffeur
routier un métier éprouvant mais qui le
passionne
toute bonne journée bon weekend aussi
Ciao
chaque jour il passe de longues heures
seul dans son camion
sur ses photos c'est sa fille Magalie ou
qu'il aille elle ne le quitte jamais
[Musique]
il y a 11 ans elle a été retrouvée morte
assassinée elle avait 19 ans ce jour-là
Eric Bertrand était sur la route il ne
se l'ai jamais pardonné
je pense que sentiment de culpabilité
tu l'as automatiquement tu dis que tu as
pas pu protéger ton enfant
tu n'étais pas là quand elle avait
besoin de toi
est-ce que c'est moi le coupable est-ce
que c'est l'assassin
voilà
moi j'étais coupable de pas être là
aujourd'hui
Eric Bertrand est rongé par ces
questions qui a tué sa fille et surtout
pourquoi
tout bascule le lundi 26 mars 2001 ce
jour-là c'est une semaine tout à fait
ordinaire qui commence pour le chauffeur
routier
voici
mon camion et puis
j'ai fait ma journée comme une autre
journée c'était une journée commune pour
moi
en début de soirée
Eric Bertrand reçoit un coup de fil à
l'autre bout du téléphone c'est Geoffrey
songres ce dernier est inquiet Magalie
n'est pas rentré du travail
je rentre à la maison de mon travail
j'offrey m'appelle il m'explique que
Magali a disparu j'essaye d'appeler
Magali à plusieurs reprises je vous
laisse des messages que tu peux faire
pour essayer de comprendre
où est passé Magalie pour Marie la
nouvelle femme d'Eric à ce moment-là il
y a forcément une explication peut-être
qu'elle a fugué elle est partie avec
quelqu'un d'autre
on se raccroche quelque part à ça parce
qu'on veut pas penser à autre chose
seulement les jours passent et Magali ne
réapparaît pas
jeudi 29 mars 2001 cela fait maintenant
trois jours qu'Eric Bertrand n'a pas eu
de nouvelles de sa fille
régulièrement il appelle enfin la
gendarmerie pour avoir des nouvelles
mais ce jour-là au téléphone on lui
annonce le pire
deux ou trois jours après j'appelle la
police qui m'annonce comme ça qu'ils ont
retrouvé Mayenne morte
de but en blanc
[Musique]
on vient pas te le dire à la maison en
prenant des gants ou quoi que ce soit
donc tout ça à la gueule
et si j'avais pas appelé moi je suis pas
quand est-ce qu'il m'aurait averti
parce que mon parapluie
c'est dans un bois à quelques kilomètres
seulement de son domicile qui a été
retrouvé le cadavre de Magali
il est en grande partie calcinée
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne le corps de Magali en
vrai je ne l'ai jamais vu
on m'a déconseillé de le voir parce que
c'était vraiment
[Musique]
pas la dernière image à garder de ma
fille j'ai vu des photos
[Musique]
c'est pas comme si tu vois le
corps vraiment je pense
mais c'est vrai que c'est très dur
c'est
des photos très très dures à voir
vous avez été gendarme pendant 32 ans
vous avez vous-même été amené à enquêter
sur des assassinats d'enfants j'imagine
que ça doit être très difficile
d'annoncer un parent que son enfant
était assassiné effectivement c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que en ce
qui me concerne je crois que c'est la
majorité des cas nous sommes tous
parents donc lorsqu'un enfant disparaît
qu'on le retrouve assassiné c'était
absolument horrible et c'est très très
difficile vis-à-vis de la famille de
pouvoir le renoncer ce qu'il faut à mon
sens éviter c'est de donner des
informations qui éventuellement les
frais se culpabiliser je vous conseille
bien que pour un parent partir d'un
instant enfin pour le cas que j'ai eu à
connaître moi une enfance coude qui
disparaît pour les parents il y a
toujours mais pourquoi je l'ai envoyé là
bas pourquoi j'ai pas fait ci pourquoi
j'ai pas fait ça donc un tas de
questions qui se posent et qui tentent
aller faire culpabiliser donc c'est
extrêmement extrêmement difficile quoi
[Musique]
Éric Bertrand
et qui a tué sa fille Magalie à cet
instant les gendarmes pensent encore que
retrouver l'assassin n'est qu'une
question de jours
il se trompe
[Musique]
aujourd'hui comme chaque semaine Annick
Canier se rend à la cathédrale de Meaux
quand je rentre dans la cathédrale je me
sens bien là c'est vraiment extra je me
sens une autre femme regarde je suis
ailleurs je suis bien dans ce havre de
paix Annick vient se recueillir prier et
déposer un cierge à la mémoire de sa
fille une fois Karine une tour papa à
mon frère Jésus-Christ moment et tout le
monde et pour les apôtres ils sont avec
nous pour tout le monde
la foi c'est ce qui a permis à Annick
cagnier de surmonter la plus terrible
des épreuves la mort tragique de sa
fille Karine il y a 18 ans
retour en 1994 le 9 juin à l'époque
Karine Leroy a 19 ans elle vit avec sa
sœur jumelle Nathalie chez leur père
[Musique]
ce matin-là Karine quitte l'appartement
pour se rendre au lycée Jean Vilar
à midi elle est supposée rentrer pour
déjeuner mais elle ne revient pas
son père est inquiet il appelle Annick
Cagnet qui vit dans une tour voisine
[Musique]
comme son père la voyait pas revenir
pour déjeuner et d'imaginer n'est pas là
qu'il aura après
chez toi
si je me souviens bien là il y a un
problème
inquiète Annick cagnier décide d'appeler
le lycée Jean Vilar au téléphone un
responsable de l'établissement lui
répond que personne n'a vu sa fille de
la journée
autrement dit karine a disparu le matin
en partant de chez elle
bon c'est là que Karine elle venait aux
huissiers Jean-Louis là et puis c'est là
qu'avec
le 9 juin 94 allait jamais arrivé parce
qu'elle était partie de chez son père et
puis en fin de compte l'a jamais arrivé
au Lycée Jean Vilar
Annick cagnier parcourt alors les
environs pour tenter de retrouver la
trace de sa fille dans un premier temps
les habitants du quartier se veulent
rassurant
[Musique]
ce n'est pas Karine que ces gens ont vu
mais sa sœur jumelle Nathalie
Karine elle reste introuvable le soir la
famille de la jeune femme décide de se
rendre à la gendarmerie c'est là qu'on
explique la situation que donc elle
était pas arrivée au lycée Jean Vilar oh
me dit vous inquiétez pas elle a fait
une fugue
comme Karine Leroy et majeur les
gendarmes pensent en toute logique à une
fugue il décide d'attendre 48 heures
avant de réagir
ma vie elle a 19 ans il s'est pas une
fugue et non que je connais sans ma vie
je suis sûr qu'il y avait quelque chose
je dis vous rendez pas compte le temps
d'attendre 48 heures on peut la tuer moi
mille fois
deux jours passent la disparition de
Karine le roi devient de plus en plus
inquiétante une fois le délai de 48
heures terminé les recherches peuvent
commencer
[Musique]
ils ont fait venir un chien pour
renifler je sais pas quoi là ils ont
commencé à interviewer tous les
locataires les premières recherches de
la gendarmerie s'avère infructueuse
l'hypothèse de la fugue devient de moins
en moins crédible
la famille de Karine commence alors à
craindre le pire
[Musique]
on savait pas où elle était on vit pu
les pleurs
c'est après on se dit ça y est on l'a
tué elle est morte
tout de suite
mais il faut continuer à vivre notamment
pour Nathalie la sœur de Karine car une
date importante arrive le 19 juin jour
de l'anniversaire des deux jumelles
comme le prouve ces images datant de
quelques années auparavant ce moment a
toujours été important pour la famille
mais ce jour-là le cœur n'y est pas
vous voulez faire donc l'anniversaire de
l'or 20 ans bon bah donc on a fait de
l'anniversaire de Nathalie mais c'est
vrai que il y avait qu'un seul gâteau il
y avait rien de tout ça donc c'était
triste bon
on avait ce qu'il faut mais
c'est vrai que il manque quelque chose
sur
regarder toutes les deux puis on
pleurait
les jours passent sans nouvelles de
Karine
jusqu'au 12 juillet ce jour-là Annick
est convoqué à la gendarmerie
je reçois un coup de téléphone ici on me
dit Madame Leroy nous avons une lettre à
vous remettre est-ce que vous pouvez
venir la gendarmerie le chercher et dans
ma tête je me dis voilà c'est mauvais on
arrive
mais je compte jusqu'à 2ème étage
là-haut ils m'ont fait à soi ils m'ont
posé une question à ce moment-là donc il
dit vous savez on a retrouvé votre fille
j'y allais morte
[Musique]
vient d'apprendre la plus terrible des
nouvelles sa fille est morte
Frédéric Malon vous êtes commissaire
divisionnaire vous dirigez le crvp
l'Office centrale pour la répression des
violences aux personnes
d'une manière globale en quoi une
enquête sur la mort d'un enfant et
particulière
sur la mort d'un enfant sont toujours
particulières parce que évidemment il y
a un côté émotionnel fort lié au fait
que ce soit un enfant qui était qui
était assassiné ce sont des enquêtes qui
évidemment sont prioritaires parmi
toutes les affaires que nous traitons au
sein de la police judiciaire
et c'est censé dans le cadre qui
évidemment monopolise le maximum de
moyens pour essayer de très rapidement
identifier le ou les auteurs et les
arrêter
humainement quand on est policier est-ce
qu'on arrive à garder du recul
parmi les policiers forcément des pères
de famille qui peuvent s'identifier un
peu aux victimes et aux familles de la
victime en tout cas notre rôle à nous
c'est justement de garder le recul de
rester technique de rester professionnel
c'est pas toujours facile mais c'est un
effort qu'on doit qu'on doit faire pour
ne pas partir non plus dans des travers
trop empathiques ou trop émotionnel
le corps de Karine a été retrouvé à
Montceaux-lès-Meaux une petite commune
située à quelques kilomètres de Meaux de
promeneurs l'ont découvert à l'orée d'un
bois
une question va alors peu à peu obséder
à Nick cannier
pourquoi un tel crime
[Musique]
quelques jours après la découverte du
corps de Magali part les recherches pour
retrouver son assassin commence
au départ la gendarmerie se veut
rassurante avec Eric Bertrand
les preuves et les indices retrouvées
sur le lieu du crime laisse à penser que
le meurtrier sera vite retrouvé
Georges Rimondi et l'avocat du père de
Magalie
lorsque l'enquête va être ouverte
d'abord les gendarmes vont assez vite
rassurer le papa Monsieur Bertrand lui
disant oh là là ils ont fait tellement
d'erreurs où il a fait tellement
d'erreurs l'auteur de ce crime
abominable que il a pratiquement signé
son crime on va devoir on va pouvoir le
retrouver assez rapidement les
enquêteurs qui viennent d'ailleurs à
établir les circonstances de la mort de
la jeune femme
le corps de Magalie a été retrouvé après
la calcination avec une espèce de forme
cylindrique qui a laissé à penser
qu'elle avait pu être brûlée soit dans
une baignoire soit dans un tonneau ou en
tout cas quelque chose de forme
cylindrique
proximité du corps de Magali
les gendarmes ont fait des recherches
tout aux alentours chercher des choses
si trouver des choses et dans son
container qui est là poubelle là voilà
ils ont retrouvé un bidon d'essence qui
pense-t-il est celui qui a servi à
allumer le feu pour que Magalie brûle
voilà l'endroit où Magali a été trouvé
n'est certainement pas l'endroit où elle
a été brûlée puisqu'il n'y a strictement
aucune trace de calcination à l'endroit
où on a retrouvé le corps de Magali
afin de mettre la main sur l'assassin
les enquêteurs recherchent alors le lieu
où le corps de Magali aurait été brûlé
encore qui fait 80% d'eau c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile donc il
faut déjà un endroit tranquille on peut
raisonnablement penser que ça peut être
dans un endroit isolé un entrepôt un
dépôt ou un squat
les recherches vont pendant un temps
s'orienter vers une maison abandonnée un
squat qui se situe à quelques kilomètres
de l'endroit où vivait Magalie
ici c'est le lieu où la police a défini
que Magali aurait peut-être été brûlé
quand je suis rentré dans cette maison
j'ai eu des sensations bizarres et puis
j'ai peut-être un pressentiment
des prélèvements sont alors effectués
dans la maison
au départ ils ont donc trouvé soi-disant
des graisses qui pensaient être humaines
et après dans la cheminée ils m'ont dit
que c'était des graisses de porc
j'ai beaucoup de doutes je sais pas
exactement ce que c'est ce qu'il en est
avocate dans le cas d'enfants assassinés
les familles sont-elles impliquées dans
les enquêtes on les tient au courant on
les met plutôt à l'écart comment ça se
passe je dirais qu'habituellement dans
les drames les policiers et les
magistrats essaient de tenir le plus
loin possible la famille d'abord pour
une raison toute simple c'est qu'elle
est souvent la première suspecte des
faits puisqu'on considère qu'à peu près
80% des affaires se passent dans
l'environnement de la victime donc on va
commencer par regarder cet environnement
avec un œil un peu suspect et donc
forcément on les tient à distance dans
un deuxième temps normalement le
magistrat est censé tenir au courant la
famille et ça va passer plutôt par
l'avocat qui va lui transmettre les
copies ou tenir son client informé mais
on a tendance toujours à avoir peur des
victimes et donc à les tenir loin de
leur dossier et c'est une erreur à mon
avis parce que souvent on constate en
discutant avec les victimes en restant à
leur côté qu'elles ont souvent des
éléments de réponse qui nous font
avancer plus vite elles se sentent aussi
seule abandonnées quelque part elle se
sentent seul mais je dirais que c'est
plus grave que cela se sentent suspecte
et c'est extrêmement difficile de vivre
cette suspicion quand on est innocent et
qu'on a perdu un proche dans des
conditions qui sont absolument
dramatiques donc elles sont doublement
victimes elles sont victimes de ce décès
de cette assassinat et elles sont
victimes du comportement de la justice
et des magistrats mais ou des enquêteurs
mais qui est nécessaire puisque
effectivement on a besoin de préserver
les indices de l'enquête dans un premier
temps et dans ce cas vous avocat vous
vous êtes les médiateurs on fait le lien
tout à fait on fait le lien entre
finalement les divers intervenants dans
la justice et nos clients alors après
chaque je dirais chaque conseil fait le
lien plus ou moins de façon plus ou
moins importante moi je tiens absolument
associer mes clients à l'enquête parce
que souvent c'est eux qui ont la bonne
idée au bon endroit au bon moment
Eric Bertrand ne comprend pas comment sa
fille magalie a pu être si brutalement
assassiné
faute d'information de la part des
forces de l'ordre il va tenter de mener
l'enquête lui-même
[Musique]
comme chaque année le 12 juillet jour de
la découverte du corps de Karine
Annick cagnier se rend à l'endroit où sa
fille a été retrouvée
à ses côtés Sophie la cousine de Karine
[Musique]
de lunettes à côté d'elle ils ont trouvé
une cafetière
oui parce que elle était tringuée
qu'elle file de cafetière électrique et
un lien de plastique ornellon des colis
là je sais pas pourquoi dans les
cervicales
dans saison
où la gendarmerie lui a demandé de venir
identifier les objets appartenant à sa
fille
la gendarme au bout d'un moment elle m'a
dit écoutez il y a des objets qui pourra
venir vérifier si c'est elle
et puis moi dans la matinée
tant qu'on sait pas bon ils étaient tous
scellés il y avait ça il y avait ça puis
alors bien sûr ils ont été nettoyés
parce que j'avais pas le droit de
toucher j'avais le droit de regarder
comme ça tu sais quand tu es comme ça on
a envie de le prendre
et ensuite bon ben j'ai regardé là j'ai
dit que je peux je dis non c'est pas ça
bague
plus près j'ai regardé enfin dans
l'espace mais si c'est elle parce que
c'est marqué mes initiales en Italie
donc voilà donc c'était bien ça
[Musique]
lorsqu'un Nick Kany repense au jour de
la disparition de sa fille elle ne peut
pas s'empêcher de s'en vouloir
[Musique]
de pour faire le chemin pour aller au
lycée Jean Vilar tous les jours je
faisais s'il y a passé
qu'on m'a fait exprès jour là je l'ai
pas fait puis peut-être que en faisant
le coucou j'aurais pu regarder le chemin
qu'elle prenait est-ce que entre temps
du bâtiment de son père le chemin est-ce
qu'il aurait pas rencontré justement
quelqu'un
vous êtes psychanalyste est-ce qu'un
parent se sent forcément coupable
lorsque son enfant est assassiné
apparent se sent quasiment toujours
coupable de tout ce qui arrive son
enfant évidemment quand son enfant est
assassiné c'est absolument tellement
tellement mais abominable c'est un mot
faible c'est tellement impensable que
évidemment que la culpabilité est
maximum parce que il y a l'idée de si
j'avais été là si ce jour-là on n'était
pas allé au supermarché si je l'avais
accompagné pour aller à l'école si il y
aura toujours mais je il faut aussi
comprendre que la culpabilité là elle a
une fonction qui est quand même
paradoxale qui est une fonction de
chercher une causalité là où le pire
probablement et qui en a pas il y en a
pas enfin cette jeune fille qu'on va
enlever assassiner alors qu'elle part à
l'école c'est le pur hasard elle s'est
trouvé au mauvais moment au mauvais
endroit ça aurait pu être quelqu'un
d'autre il y a aucun lien
rationnel qui permet d'expliquer ça donc
on est au fond plongé au moins
inconsciemment dans un monde qui a plus
de sens et se dire c'est de ma faute
c'est une façon de remettre une
causalité qui fait que le monde une
certaine logique dans le monde c'est
tout à fait abominable mais c'est ça
sert quand même aussi à ça et puis la
mort d'un enfant c'est quelque chose
d'envoyer qui avait perdu une fille un
petit fils disait qu'on pouvait pas s'en
remettre mais il a probablement raison
enfin c'est le seul deuil qu'on peut pas
faire parce que c'est le monde à
l'envers enfin voir ses enfants mourir
avant soi qu'est-ce qu'on peut quand
même qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de pire
et l'assassinat c'est absolument atroce
parce que parce que évidemment le parent
ne peut que se représenter et sa croix
sa culpabilité ce Cadu vivre l'enfant
avant qu'on ne le tue enfin soit la
façon dont il est mort soit le viol s'il
y a eu lieu avant enfin c'est
l'abomination des abominations
pour Annick Canier le travail de deuil
ne pourra vraiment se faire que lorsque
l'on aura retrouvé l'assassin de sa
fille
à l'époque un jeune homme est vide
soupçonné il s'agit d'un ancien petit
ami de l'adolescente
[Musique]
Louis Ragon se souvient qu'à l'époque
les enquêteurs avaient été intrigués par
un élément bien précis il y avait le
coût de la ficelle qui avait servi à
étrangler Karine qui servait pour
ficeler les les
publicités destinées à la distribution
et lui avait fait de la distribution cet
individu
finalement faute de preuve les
enquêteurs ne peuvent inculper le jeune
homme le principal suspect est donc
relâché
[Musique]
l'affaire Karine Leroy tombe peu à peu
dans l'oubli et l'enquête est au point
mort mais les conséquences tragiques du
drame vont peu à peu se multiplier
[Musique]
depuis la mort de Magali part son père
Eric rend régulièrement visite au
fermier qui a retrouvé le corps de sa
fille il veut essayer de comprendre ce
qui a bien pu se passer ce lundi 26 mars
je suis Éric le papa de Magali qui a été
c'est monsieur qui a trouvé Magali
je suis parti au champignon et que j'ai
eu la mauvaise surprise de trouver le
cordes Magalie
au premier moment j'ai cru que c'était
une branche j'ai vu qu'une que le bras
et sa main en fait et après je suis moi
je suis revenu tout de suite ici il y a
le médecin qui était venu voir ma
grand-mère et
c'est là que j'ai dit que j'avais vu
encore
que je pensais que c'était un corps et
il est venu avec moi à constater etc
c'était vraiment ça
ciao
à l'endroit où le corps de sa fille a
été retrouvé
Eric Bertrand ne peut s'empêcher de
revivre le scénario du drame
j'imagine la voiture garée ici la
personne sort si elle est seule prendre
un corps dans le coffre un corps inerte
et puis le déposer ici
là au bord de la route
avec le pied qui dépassait pratiquement
sur la route comme ça
je reviens de temps en temps je fais des
recherches le plus possible essayer de
trouver les affaires de Magali essayez
de
trouver des indices où elle a pu être
brûlée ou j'ai pris ce chemin jusqu'à en
haut jusqu'à
ce pèlerinage
Eric Bertran
D car depuis la mort de sa fille il se
sent délaissé par les autorités
[Musique]
vraiment mal informé tu n'es pas informé
du tout de tes droits à ce moment là il
y a rien
qui me dise que je dois faire on dit pas
que tu as le droit de porter participe
par exemple on te dit pas ben vous
pouvez vous pouvez peut-être voir un
psychologue tu peux y penser toi-même en
même temps mais c'est vrai que
t'as pas que ça a pensé non c'est bon là
ni mon ex-épouse ni mes enfants vont mes
enfants sont petits
maisons qu'une aide non plus on leur
propose pas d'aide psychologique on leur
non leur sœur a été assassiné mais c'est
normal
Eric Bertrand aurait voulu être informé
conseillé ou au moins écouter
désormais ils se sont avant tout
révoltés
[Musique]
quels sont les autres sentiments qui
sont impliqués ils ça dépend vraiment
des gens la colère est normale je fais
pas du tout partie des gens qui pensent
qu'il faut rétablir la peine de mort
pour les assassins d'enfants pour autant
je comprends vraiment que des parents
aient envie d'assassiner quelqu'un qui
qui a tué leur enfant parce que c'est
une réaction normale enfin c'est comment
faire pour pour le venger dans une
société civilisée on ne se venge pas
donc évidemment je suis contre ça mais
c'est complètement compréhensible il y a
la colère il y a il y a la culpabilité
ça peut ça peut tout à fait si quelqu'un
n'est pas aidé soit par son entourage
soit par un psy ça peut donner une forme
de de d'État dépressif ou plus rien dans
la vie n'a de sens pour lui bon ça peut
vraiment donner donner mille choses et
quand on ne connaît pas le coupable
c'était encore plus violent c'est plus
violent parce que l'affaire ne peut pas
être close c'est comme si la tombe ne
pouvait pas se refermer en plus il y a
l'idée quand même que on doit à l'enfant
de rechercher qui lui a fait ça et de le
faire punir donc on est en dette et
fruits très bien ça que si perturbe le
deuil la culpabilité quelque chose qui
perturbe le deuil tant qu'on est hanté
par l'idée de si j'avais fait si j'avais
pas fait ça ça ne serait pas arrivé on
peut pas laisser les les le travail de
deuil se faire
[Musique]
en dépit des nombreux indices l'enquête
n'avance pas
pour Eric Bertrand l'incertitude est
insupportable il n'a alors plus qu'une
seule solution faire appel aux médias
nous sommes en 1997 cela fait trois ans
que Karine Leroy a été assassiné
l'absence de leur fille le deuil
impossible l'assassin en liberté autant
d'éléments qui rendent cette épreuve
insupportable pour ses parents et cette
année-là Michel le père de Karine décède
des suites d'une crise cardiaque il n'a
que 56 ans
Michel moi je pense que oui ça l'a
atteint profondément lorsqu'on me dit
Michel est mort une crise cardiaque je
n'ai pas été étonné
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tard c'est Annick
Canier qui est elle victime d'un
accident vasculaire cérébral
derrière
on fait souvent des AVC
maintenant
un moment c'était la jambe tout le côté
gauche qui avait pris quoi ça avait pété
là on va dire et puis c'est tout ce côté
là qui est mort malgré tout la famille
tente de continuer à vivre nous sommes
le 19 juin 2012 aujourd'hui tout le
monde s'est réuni pour fêter
l'anniversaire de Nathalie la jumelle de
Karine
bon anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
38 ans la vieille
pour Nathalie cette date autrefois
symbole de jours heureux et devenu une
épreuve douloureuse
longtemps elle a refusé de célébrer son
anniversaire
il y a des années vous voulez pas du
moment fait rien je faisais quand même
elle veut pas parce que du chagrin parce
que ça sort n'est pas là mais elle a
besoin qu'on s'occupe d'elle
comme chaque année juste après la
réception Annick se rend au cimetière
pour se recueillir sur les tombes de
Karine et de son ex-mari Michel
mon frère Jésus-Christ bonjour mon frère
[Musique]
là je vais les mettre là
on va peut-être pas je vais mettre là
c'est pour toi
alors je vais payer je lui parle
plus rien comme si je parle dans le vide
mais enfin pour moi pour moi c'est pas
dans le vide après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une fois qu'on va faire son papa
bon c'était quand même un bon mari à mon
père je suis mourir voilà
mon lit pour lui c'était un deuil France
peut-être je sais pas
bon on va y aller
fais un bisou
[Applaudissements]
regarder l'enfant en tête et alors
travail de deuil c'est un mot qu'on met
aujourd'hui vraiment à toutes les sauces
et pour n'importe quoi bon ça veut la
souffrance elle s'en va jamais elle se
transforme jusqu'à ne plus empêcher
totalement de vivre c'est le principe de
la cicatrice si vous voulez vous recevez
un coup de couteau bon ça ne saigne plus
au bout d'un certain temps ensuite ça va
se refermer il va y avoir une très
grosse cicatrice et puis peu à peu la
cicatrice va changer de forme mais la
cicatrice elle va rester donc de toute
façon quiconque a perdu son enfant et
encore plus quiconque a vu son enfant
assassiné
martyrisé trop c'est une marque qui
n'est pas ça il sera plus jamais jamais
le même après mais il y a cette idée que
si le coupable est puni ça remet quand
même le monde sur ses pieds
[Musique]
les mois et les années passent et le
meurtrier de Magali n'a toujours pas été
retrouvé d'abord confiant dans le
travail des enquêteurs
Eric Bertrand finit par se rendre compte
que l'assassin de sa fille risque de
n'être jamais retrouvé
au bout d'un moment je m'aperçois que
que cet enquête elle part en sucette
qu'on m'a dit n'importe quoi qu'on
et j'ai envie
peut-être que les médias en parlent pour
pas que ce crime soit oublié désespéré
il veut médiatiser l'affaire de sa fille
les médias français s'intéressent peu à
la ferme égalit pas alors Éric Bertrand
décide de se tourner vers la télévision
suisse
qui a été tué dans les circonstances
atroces et en 2003 il participe à cette
émission qui sera entièrement consacrée
à la disparition de sa fille
malheureusement elle ne permettra pas
d'apporter d'éléments nouveaux
[Musique]
Céline la cousine de Magali apporte
aussi son soutien à Éric grâce à
internet elle fait tout pour que le
meurtre de la jeune fille ne tombe pas
dans l'oubli
je voulais qu'un maximum de gens soient
au courant de ce qui s'était passé pour
Magalie de notre histoire de son
histoire et de là Eric qui m'a dit mais
oui on va faire une page pour Magali
on y trouve des photos que les gens
mettent on y trouve quelques photos de
Magali que j'ai mis moi en créant le
site tous les jours situe tous les soirs
quand je rentre du travail je suis sur
la page facebook je suis certain que
l'assassin il est aussi sur cette page
je suis certain aujourd'hui
Eric Bertrand et hanté par le meurtre de
sa fille il se recueille régulièrement
sur la tombe de ma Cali
l'entrée du cimetière Magali est
maintenant
et pour toujours
[Musique]
dans l'espoir que malgré tout l'enquête
aboutisse un jour il a fait le choix de
ne pas sceller la tombe de sa fille
je veux pas fermer complètement parce
que on sait jamais des fois qui est
encore des prélèvements à faire ou si
des fois des ADN seraient plus
performants puis qu'ils en est encore
besoin on sait jamais tant que l'enquête
est pas résolue je vais laisser la tombe
comme ça pour l'instant
[Musique]
même là maintenant 11 ans après le deuil
on l'a pas fait
tant que tu mettras pas un nom sur qui a
fait ça tu peux pas faire ton travail de
deuil s'arrange c'est ça le terme exact
ça te ronge
[Musique]
ce que redoute beaucoup ces familles
c'est la clôture de l'affaire c'est
c'est comme une deuxième mort de leurs
enfants pourquoi est-ce qu'on clôture
les dossiers au bout d'un moment alors
on clôture historiquement parce qu'on a
instauré cette notion de prescription
c'est-à-dire qu'au bout de 10 ans après
l'effet ou de 10 ans après le dernier
acte on va clore le dossier et
finalement c'est historique puisque faut
dire que dans le siècle passé les
personnes décédées plus vite et donc les
témoignages et les preuves se
disparaissaient plus vite aujourd'hui
avec la police technique aujourd'hui
avec les enregistrements c'est
incroyable de garder cette notion de
prescription
c'est rien et surtout je dirais que
c'est la Libye de la justice pour pas
continuer à chercher et moi je suis très
en colère contre la prescription mais
finalement on peut la contourner cette
notion de prescription et je suis
doublement en colère contre je dirais
les magistrats et les enquêteurs qui
finalement acceptent de fermer un
dossier au bout de deux ans ça arrive
encore aujourd'hui au bout de deux ans
on dit bon on a rien trouvé donc on va
arrêter de chercher c'est l'heure de
voir c'est leur responsabilité et je
pense qu'il faut engager la
responsabilité de l'État lorsqu'elle
rend un en lieu dans des dossiers de
crimes de sang je pense que la justice
ne devrait jamais rendre de non-lieu
c'est je dirais la responsabilité des
magistrats et des enquêteurs de
continuer à chercher j'ai envie de dire
aux victimes c'est à vous de prendre
votre histoire en main il faut pas faire
confiance à la justice il faut pas faire
confiance aux enquêteurs il faut
continuer à être la présence un petit
peu comme le poêle à gratter de cette
justice en disant mais j'ai droit à une
réponse j'ai droit de savoir vous devez
continuer à chercher ce que vous en tant
qu'avocat vous conseillez à vos clients
de faire appel aux médias pour lancer un
dossier pour éviter la clôture je dirais
que c'est toujours douloureux de
s'exposer dans sa souffrance mais c'est
vrai que les médias vont permettre de
faire remonter des indices vont
permettre de refaire remonter des
témoignages qui vont empêcher le juge de
rendre ce dont lieu et donc oui parfois
dans des dossiers on a vraiment rien on
leur conseille de le faire et on
s'associe avec eux
[Musique]
12 ans après l'assassinat de Magalie par
la famille a le sentiment que la justice
les a abandonnés
ils ne pourront trouver la paix que le
jour où le meurtrier sera arrêté
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant 18 ans que Karine
est parti
aujourd'hui sa maman a ni gagner vit à
travers ses souvenirs
pour l'aider à surmonter sa douleur de
mer elle s'est créée une sorte de
mausolée qui lui permet d'entretenir le
souvenir de sa fille là c'est comme si
c'était autour de l'armoire j'étais mon
petit cimetière à moi dans cette pièce
Annick aime être seul et parler à sa
fille comme si elle était encore en vie
on va tu me manques c'est vrai ça fait
18 ans je l'ai parti t'a quitté la terre
tu es parti au paradis avec papa du ciel
comme je suis toujours mais de la
meilleure vue t'inquiète pas c'est
là-haut dans cet univers les objets
associés aux souvenirs côtoient les
gestes symboliques
Anthony qui maintenant il est petite
sœur récolté ça il tendresse voilà
pour moi c'est c'est comme si ça
représentait mes enfants voilà tous les
matins quand je me change quoi que ce
soit et bien je prends la photo à Karine
qui faisait
bon ben à tout à l'heure
je remets ça comme ça
pour Annick Canier c'est un peu comme si
le temps s'était arrêté ce jour funeste
du 9 juin 1994
etter j'ai l'année de décès à Karine on
va dire encore ça car et puis donc
actuellement pour moi je viens de le
voir parce que bon ben en voyant la date
là je pense à ma vie bien sûr alors je
vais marquer que dans le 12 c'était
retrouvé
assassiné donc appris par le 13 par les
gendarmes
l'enterrement donc ça a été fait le 23
18 ans après la disparition de Karine
Leroy son assassin n'a jamais été arrêté
et il semble peu probable qu'on le
retrouve un jour
un sentiment d'injustice pour cette mère
condamnée à jamais à pleurer son enfant
ma vie est finie depuis 9 juin 94 je
suis là sans être là
on dit que maintenant on dirait que
maintenant je suis de
voilà
on va dire
[Musique]
mais est-ce que les parents dans ma
situation c'est pareil
peut-être qu'ils arrivent à continuer à
vivre peut-être je leur souhaite
mais moi j'arrive pas
en attendant qu'un jour on retrouve
l'assassin de Magali
Eric Bertrand continue de vivre pour ses
autres enfants
un précieux soutien qui lui permet de ne
pas perdre espoir
tu peux pas t'imaginer
que ton enfant puisse mourir avant toi
chaque jour de ta vie te dit mais
pourquoi
tu as pas de réponse
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui peut faire qu'une personne
puisse faire une telle horreur
[Musique]
j'ai pas de réponse
deux destin d'une mère et d'un père
brisé à jamais
uni dans un même combat que l'assassin
de leur enfant soit retrouvé et jugé
ils pourront alors peut-être essayer de
tourner la page
[Musique]
sur que jusqu'au bout de ma vie
je chercherai à savoir qui il est et
pourquoi il a fait ça